our Margaret Brennan spoke with Iranian
Foreign Minister Javad Zarif on Sunday's
Face the Nation she asked the reef about
the possibility of a new agreement
between the US and its allies if the US
and its allies come to their own
agreement on the sidelines to address
some of the things that President Trump
is concerned about will you accept that
no because what is important is for the
Europeans to bring the United States
into compliance because Iran has been in
compliance with the deal it's been the
United States that has failed to comply
Face the Nation moderator and CBS News
senior foreign affairs correspondent
Margaret Brennan is with us from
Washington Margaret good morning what
exactly is new about this quote-unquote
new deal and will the Iranians even
entertain it at all well as you heard
from javad zarif who knows this deal
inside and out because he negotiated the
2015 version of it they would consider
any kind of loss of economic benefits
loss of sanctions relief to be a
violation on America's part and
therefore unleash their nuclear program
what American UK and French diplomats
along with the Germans are furiously
working on here is some kind of side
agreement that would help save face that
would essentially let president Trump
walk away saying he fixed it he got
these things he's concerned about dealt
with in a side deal that wouldn't
violate the original Obama era agreement
it's essentially a workaround but no one
sure yet if they can convince President
Trump that that's going to be good
enough for him to walk away from this
campaign promise to tear up the deal or
if Iran won't consider that a violation
and therefore be able to start up their
nuclear program again Margaret in that
same interview the foreign minister told
you that if he pulls out if we pull out
that there are many options and it would
not be pleasant what did he mean by that
and what's at stake well specifically he
said they could restart their nuclear
development at a much faster rate if the
u.s. is in violation so that means not
just do
the things that President Trump already
says they're doing which is continuing
to develop missiles true and continuing
to meddle elsewhere in the Middle East
and sponsor terrorism true but as
defense secretary mattis said this isn't
a friendship agreement this is something
that he wants president Trump to agree
to stay part of because it deals with
this narrow set of issues just freezing
their nuclear program and at this moment
the US intelligence community believes
Iran is abiding by its terms so the
national security team would prefer that
President Trump stay with the deal and
then work with our allies to counter
other bad behavior instead of twisting
the arms of our friends France and
Germany to extract these new concessions
all right Margaret thank you